[Musica]
e siamo al cervello di un bambino di un
anno
sapete quante nuove connessioni si
formano ogni secondo tra i suoi neuroni
circa 700 in un'intera giornata fanno
più di 60 milioni di nuove connessioni e
ciascuna di queste nuove connessioni
rappresenta una nuova sfumatura un nuovo
concetto che il bambino ha imparato del
mondo tramite la sua esperienza
i bambini sono i campioni
dell'apprendimento ed è a loro che
guardano le tecniche più moderne
l'intelligenza artificiale
a distanza di circa 50 60 anni da quando
alan turing lo aveva teorizzato per la
prima volta si sta facendo finalmente
strada il concetto che se vogliamo
creare dei sistemi autonomi davvero
intelligenti non dobbiamo cercare di
infondere loro tutta la nostra
conoscenza bensì dobbiamo renderli
capaci di apprendere nella maniera più
efficiente ed autonoma possibile la
prima volta che ha avuto a che fare con
l'intelligenza artificiale
avevo circa 15 anni e nel mio tempo
libero per quanto questo possa suonare
un po nerd nel mio tempo libero
avevo creato un piccolo programma un
piccolo giochino in cui un berlino
virtuale doveva fuggire da un lupo pena
essere divorato la cosa particolare è
che non avevo programmato pierino per
scappare dal lupo bensì gli avevo dato
soltanto la possibilità di muoversi
all'interno di una piccola mappa che
avevo dato la possibilità di vedere il
lupo ma soprattutto lui ha votato della
capacità di apprendere dall'esperienza
tramite un semplice algoritmo
l'intelligenza artificiale è così
dopo averlo lanciato in questo mondo
acceso il programma ho visto pierino
prima imparare che stare nei pressi del
lupo non era una grande idea e poi
addirittura imparare a scappare il più
velocemente possibile non appena lo
vedesse in lontananza
ed è così che mi sono innamorato
dell'intelligenza artificiale e ancora
oggi che progettare sistemi intelligenti
artificiale è il mio lavoro e del fuoco
e stai facendo che ho fondato
ancora oggi vedere sistemi di
intelligenza artificiale imparare
autonomamente a prendere decisioni solo
tramite l'esperienza sui dati che gli
mettiamo a disposizione e per me
qualcosa di veramente magico ora sono
passati quasi vent'anni da quel da quel
momento da quel pierino virtuale e oggi
la tecnologia è tutta un'altra cosa
di fatto l'intelligenza artificiale oggi
tra noi ad esempio in grado di guidare
in maniera più sicura di noi umani è in
grado di batterci a giochi di strategia
che fino a qualche anno fa sembravano di
dominio solamente umano assolutamente è
in grado di riconoscerci noi i nostri
amici quando carichiamo foto su facebook
ma soprattutto ci aiuta in tantissimi
ambiti già oggi dalla finanza fino alla
medicina la frontiera tecnologica è
rappresentata dal tip learning
l'apprendimento profondo e di planning
si fonda sulla costruzione di cervelli
virtuali dotate di migliaia di neuroni e
milioni di connessioni e impara tramite
la riorganizzazione di queste
connessioni dopo ogni prova ed errore
che effettua sui dati che gli mettiamo a
disposizione durante l'allenamento
quindi durante la fase di allenamento
prova a prendere decisioni ci prende
sbaglia e nel frattempo riorganizza le
connessioni all'interno del suo cervello
virtuale e così facendo imparo proprio
come un bambino
quindi il problema è che
proprio come un bambino che diventa
adulto anche per questi sistemi di
intelligenza artificiale più conoscenza
significa meno flessibilità
nell'apprendimento quindi più conoscenza
meno flessibilità nell'apprendimento e
questo è un problema ed è un problema
che si esemplifica in particolare in
un'altra tecnica avanzata di
intelligenza artificiale chiamata
reinforcement learning cioè
apprendimento per rinforzo rinforzo nel
earning funziona tramite ricompense
virtuali e punizioni virtuali che
vengono date al sistema a seconda
dell'esito di ogni sua decisione quindi
ad esempio un sistema di mainfirst
mulder nin che sta imparando a giocare a
scacchi verrà ricompensato ogni
qualvolta fa una mossa che lo mette in
una posizione di vantaggio rispetto
all'avversario
mentre viene punito virtualmente quando
invece fa una mossa non opportuno così
facendo man mano giocando tante partite
il sistema impara
il problema è che quello che si verifica
che dopo un po dopo che ha imparato un
po il sistema tende di fronte a
situazioni simili a scegliere sempre la
prima strada che gli aveva portato una
ricompensa in passato quindi di fronte a
situazioni simili va sul sicuro ha paura
di sbagliare e questo rappresenta un
enorme problema perché non è detto che
la prima strada che ci ha portato nel
compenso se anche la strada che ci
conduce al successo maggiore dico segue
di conseguenza ci si è inventati un
escamotage è l'escamotage consiste di
quando in quando non sempre però di
quando in quando durante l'allenamento
del sistema di impedirgli totalmente di
provare paura di sbagliare quindi ogni
tanto al sistema non ha paura di
sbagliare e si sente libero di
sperimentare nuove strade prenderemo le
decisioni così facendo la maggior parte
delle volte fallisce miseramente
ovviamente per ogni tanto scoprirà una
nuova strada una nuova strategia un po
creativa un po diversa che lo porta alla
fine un risultato nettamente migliore
ed è proprio
tramite queste tecniche questo genere di
tecniche che hanno in comune il fatto di
mirare a consentire sistemi
l'intelligenza artificiale di sbagliare
di più non di meno durante la fase di
addestramento durante la fase della loro
formazione che oggi l'intelligenza
artificiale raggiunto è successo che
conosciamo e non è ironico
tutto questo non è ironico che proprio
noi umani che critichiamo gli errori
degli altri che critichiamo aspramente
che ci prova e sbaglia siamo anche
quelli che stanno regalando il valore
dell'errore all'intelligenza artificiale
stiamo regalando il valore dell'errore
all'intelligenza artificiale
quando potremo imparare così tanto
proprio da questa ad esempio nel deep
learning cerchiamo in tutti i modi di
impedire al sistema di memorizzare i
dati che gli mettiamo a disposizione
durante l'allenamento perché se così
facesse perderebbe totalmente la
flessibilità di adattarsi a situazioni
nuove
e allora perché noi umani obblighiamo ad
esempio i nostri bambini a impiegare
tantissimo tempo a imparare a memoria
date e dati che inevitabilmente
dimenticheranno alla prima verifica
perché il sistema educativo spesso
ancora si fonda più e premia di più la
memorizzazione rispetto che la
comprensione e ancora nel rimpasto in
learning abbiamo visto che la paura di
sbagliare viene vista come un problema
per cui si cerca di ogni tanto
consentire durante la formazione di non
avere paura di sbagliare affinché il
sistema possa scoprire strada e che lo
portano quei successi più grandi
e allora perché tra noi quando qualcuno
cambia strada durante la propria
formazione o addirittura durante la sua
carriera lavorativa viene visto come uno
scapestrato totale perché chi cambia
idea
in seguito ad esperienze di vita in
seguito a riflessioni è prima visto come
inconsistente
faccio e infine abbiamo visto che
sappiamo che l'intelligenza artificiale
impara qualcosa tutte le volte che
sbaglia e allora perché continuiamo a
vedere l'errore come una sconfitta
quando in realtà è soltanto il primo
passo sulla strada del cambiamento del
successo grazie
[Applauso]